we're clearly going to have global  family and i'm a very positive thinking  type of a man you know i just don't see  a way out of this at this point even  though it hasn't really started in  earnest yet it's all about conditions  again amateurs always talk sparks it's  about conditions the conditions are set  for a huge global famine say somebody  watching this is concerned about famine  is there anything that the average  person can do to either prepare or fight  back it depends on your conditions right  how you should prepare um  if you live on key west so you've got  one set of issues you're also not going  to have a big farm right you know i mean  you're not going to grow anything down  there or if you live in hawaii imports  about 90 percent of the food  you're going to be short you're going to  be bidding against the world on the  price of that food right